hey everyone it's sarah with
registerednessrn.com and in this video
i'm going to demonstrate how to count
the respirations in an infant
and of course perform hand hygiene
before beginning
and a normal respiratory rate in an
infant is about 30 to 60 breaths per
minute
so before we even start counting
respirations we want to look at that
infant and we want to make sure that
they're not in any respiratory distress
so one way we can tell is we can look at
the nose infants
love to breathe through their nose so we
were checking their nostrils and we're
looking for nasal flaring and if you see
that that's not a good sign
also you want to look at that chest and
you want to look for anything
like chest retractions and what that
looks like it literally looks like the
skin has just been pulled over the ribs
and you can see the ribs very well and
this infant does not have
either of those things in addition you
want to look at the infant's skin color
and make sure it's appropriate for
their skin tone and that you don't see
any signs and symptoms of cyanosis
so to count respirations what we're
going to do is we're going to count for
one
full minute the rise in the fall of the
chest now with an adult you probably
remember that if the rate was regular we
could count for 30 seconds and multiply
by 2.
well this isn't the case with the infant
you're gonna do it for one full minute
because infants breathing pattern is
irregular
they have what's called periodic
breathing where they'll breathe and then
they'll stop for a second so we're gonna
count for one full minute and we're
looking
at that rise and that fall of the chest
and infants like to breathe um
abdominally so
if you're having trouble what you could
do is you could lightly
place your hand on the chest and feel
the rise in the fall
but you want to be careful not to
disturb the infant and
get them crying so i'll demonstrate and
i'll count with each rise
and with each fall just to give you an
example so
here we go one two three four
five six 7 8
9 10. so you want to count that rise and
that fall for
one full minute and then document that
number
so his respirations were 38 which again
is normal because the normal rate is
about 30 to 60 breaths per minute
okay so that wraps up this video on how
to assess respirations in an
infant and be sure to check out the
other videos in this pediatrics series